الجزء الصعب هو معرفة كيفية القيام
بذلك بطريقة مدعومة ، فليس من السهل ،
كما تعلمون ، أن بناء أمازون لم يكن سهلاً ،
فقد تطلب الكثير من العمل الشاق لمجموعة من
زملائه الأذكياء للغاية
وأعتقد أن لورين وجدت الشيء نفسه  الشيء
الذي يجعل العمل الخيري متشابهًا جدًا ،
ليس من السهل حقًا أنه من الصعب حقًا أن
أحد الأشياء التي لا أحبها
في البيئة الحالية هو أنني
أعتقد أن هناك الكثير من الانقسام وأعتقد
أن الناس يستخدمون الصراع كأداة
لتحقيق غاياتهم الخاصة  لا أعتقد
أنها أداة جيدة
[تصفيق]
أجنبي
هل قلت مائة مليون دولار
عندما يكون الناس في وضع يمكنهم من
مساعدتك يجب أن تساعد
[تصفيق]
لذلك  نصيحتي للناس سواء أكانوا
أصحاب أعمال صغيرة أم أنك تعرف هل
تأخذ بعض المخاطرة بعيدًا عن الطاولة إذا كنت
ستجري عملية شراء ربما
تبطئ عملية الشراء هذه قليلاً واحتفظ
ببعض المسحوق الجاف في متناول اليد وانتظر
قليلاً و  انظر كيف تحاول تقليل بعض المخاطر
في يو  اور في عملك او حياتك
اجنبيه